mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalker
a right triangle contains an inscribed
rectangle as shown
the distance from the top of the
rectangle to the top vertex of the
triangle is equal to four units
the distance from the right side of the
rectangle to the right vertex is equal
to 3 units
part 1
what is the area of the rectangle equal
to
part 2
what is the minimum area for a triangle
that satisfies these conditions
i find part 2 to be particularly
interesting because variations of it
have been used in university entrance
exams and in job interviews
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
we will first solve for the area of the
rectangle and then we will solve for the
minimum area of the triangle
so let's get started with part one
we have a right triangle
we'll label the right angle
suppose one angle is equal to a and the
other angle is equal to b
now construct the rectangle
we have right angles here and here
in this right triangle one angle is
equal to a which means the other angle
will be equal to b
then in this right triangle one angle is
equal to b which means the other angle
will be equal to a
thus these two right triangles are
similar to each other
now we are given that this leg is equal
to four and this other leg is equal to
3.
suppose the rectangle has a horizontal
length equal to x and a vertical length
equal to y
because these two right triangles are
similar we have four divided by x
is equal to y divided by three
we can then cross multiply to get that x
times y is equal to four times three
which is equal to twelve
but x times y is exactly the area of the
rectangle
thus the area of the rectangle is always
equal to 12.
that's the answer to part 1.
now let's solve for part two
the minimum area for a triangle that
satisfies these conditions
here is one such triangle that satisfies
these conditions
we can measure the base of the triangle
and the height of the triangle and we'll
calculate the triangle's area as
one-half the base times the height
we can then vary the parameters of this
triangle
we can change the value of the base of
the triangle and the height will adjust
accordingly
we'll see that each triangle has a
different area
the question is what is the minimum area
for a triangle that satisfies these
conditions how do we solve that
first we will write an expression for
the area of this large triangle
it'll be equal to the sum of the
following three areas
one area is the area of this right
triangle this right triangle has an area
that's equal to four x over two
we then add the area of this triangle
which is equal to three y over two
finally we add the area of this
rectangle which is equal to x times y
we already solved that x times y is
equal to 12 so we can substitute that in
then we can solve this equation for y
y is equal to 12 over x
we can then substitute in for y
we will then simplify this expression
it'll be equal to 18 divided by x
we now have a formula for the area of
the large triangle just in terms of the
variable x
it'll be equal to 2x plus 18 over x plus
12.
we'll say this is f of x and that's the
area of the large triangle
we want to minimize this area
so we'll take the first derivative which
will be equal to 2 minus 18 over x
squared
we'll set that equal to zero
we thus have 2 is equal to 18 over x
squared which means that x squared is
equal to 18 over 2 which is equal to 9
then x is equal to 3 because we only
want to consider positive lengths we
want x to be greater than zero
x equals three is a critical value and
we can check using the second derivative
test that this is indeed a minimum
thus the minimum area will happen when x
is equal to three
from here
we can substitute in
we can see that x is equal to 3 will
correspond that y is equal to 4.
so interestingly
the area is minimum when these two small
right triangles are congruent
then what is the area of the large
triangle
we'll substitute it in for f of x and
then simplify
we'll get that f of 3 is equal to 24
units squared and that's the answer
that's the minimum area for a triangle
that satisfies these conditions
what an interesting interview question
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
you